[Music]
do you know what a night nanny this they
take care of the baby at night so mom
and dad can get some sleep I don't want
to stranger in my house it's like a
Lifetime movie we're the nanny tries to
kill the family and the mom it survives
and she has to walk with a cane at the
end
get over yourself mom what's wrong with
your body
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telly I'm here to take care of you
I'm just not used to people doing things
for me I hold a baby all day and then
night time rolls around and I'm supposed
to just switch gears like hello I'm all
sexy now you're empty yeah
no you're empty on this side your 20's
are great but then your thirties come
around the corner like a garbage truck
at 5:00 a.m.
girl skill no you know we might look
like we're all better but if you look
close recovered even sailor
you're convinced the year this failure
but you actually means your biggest
dream come true
if you want to run off for something
then get that cuz I wanna do that too
sometimes I'm not gonna I'm here to help
you with everything and can't fix the
parts without treating the whole yeah no
one's treated my oh and a really long
time
[Music]